thank you all for choosing to attend
this talk today I am my name is Melissa
McNeil and I'm really excited to talk to
you about customizable probabilistic
record linkage and to debut a tool
called name match that I've been working
on for the last many years and it just
got open sourced last week so
um really exciting and really excited to
get to share it with you all today
so this is going to be our agenda for
today
um I'll start sort of by talking about
record linkage more generally and
specifically we'll go through what it is
why it matters why we are trying to
solve it with machine learning and why
it can be really difficult
then we will sort of focus in on the
name match tool specifically I'll go
through what makes it special what it
requires and how you can use it and then
we'll end with a full example
um but before we dive in I'll just give
a little bit of background about me so
um as was said in the intro I'm a data
scientist at the University of Chicago
crime lab the crime lab's mission is to
design test and scale data science
Innovations to improve the public
sector's response to the Dual crises of
gun violence and America's broken
criminal justice system
so what our work looks like is that we
we partner with non-profits and local
government agencies to answer research
questions using data and so as you might
imagine a lot of those projects that we
do require record linkage as a first
step
um and so I've been at the crime lab
for a little over six years now all the
while developing record linkage tools
and using them to make our projects
possible and specifically over the last
couple years I've been working closely
with zuban jelva and Eddie Lynn to
generalize these record linkage tools
into the name match tool the open source
tool that it is today
okay so what is record linkage
um when I say record linkage throughout
this talk what I'm talking about is sort
of the general task of figuring out
which records refer to the same person
within or across data sets so um if you
imagine that we have these three data
sets
um record linkage could help us figure
out that these three records all refer
to the same person
and so on so on and so on until all of
our records across all the data sets
have been associated with the other
records that refer to the same person
and so after we've done record linkage
we have figured out that there's these
four people exist in our data set and
not only do we know like that there's
four people but we know exactly which
records refer to each one of them
so why is this important
um record linkage is often a really
critical prerequisite to many analytic
tasks and so that could be tasks like
linking data sets together
um deduplicating a data set that has
multiple records per person that you
want to collapse down to the person
level
and then also a big one is the ability
to understand a person's history over
time and this could really be any type
of History so you can apply it to
whatever field you're in and this could
be medical history criminal history
purchasing history voting history and
really any type of situation where
a person shows up in a data set over
time because of incident have happened
to them throughout time record linkage
can also can often be really helpful in
connecting those records so that you can
like create features about a person's
history and outcomes
um so I'm going to go through two quick
examples to just really hopefully drive
home the point that this is
um really valuable and the first example
comes from my own field so
um program evaluation is something that
like government agencies non-profits
social science researchers like us at
the crime lab often do to demonstrate
the effectiveness of new programs or
interventions in the real world and so
this often involves linking data sets to
answer questions like which individuals
from our study applied for public
benefits in the next year or which
individuals in our study were arrested
in the next 18 months so you're often
linking like a study roster data set to
some really large administrator
and then hopefully again this next
example really like hits home for
everyone in this room because it applies
to a lot of different fields
um so any type of individualized
prediction that you do which this is
kind of like become a buzzword in the
age of big data and machine learning but
um like it whether you're predicting
College acceptance or heart attack
rearrest customer churn
if you have data that has events about
people over time then you're going to
need to associate those records with a
person's identity in order to build the
features and outcomes that you need to
to do those prediction models
okay so now that we know a little bit
about what record language is and why
it's important
turn to talk about why we think we can
solve it with machine learning
and I think the main reason for me is
that at its core record linkage is just
a series of prediction problems
so again and again you're asking
yourselves do these two records refer to
the same person yes or no so so we're
looking at data and we're making a
prediction if it's the same person or
not
or not and another reason that this is a
perfect task for machine learning is
that the human like the features that
you would think about in order to make
this prediction are really easy for a
computer to understand as well
so to go through this example we see a
record for John Smith we see another
record for also John Smith but no h of
the the name
and I I think as a human trying to make
this prediction your mind was first go
to like okay the first names have one
character difference those names have
zero character difference the dobs are
exactly the same so these are like the
the features that we sort of start
filling out in our
in order to make this description
and you know Computing the distance
between strings is like something a
computer can very easily do
um and so after we observe these
features we might make the prediction
that this is the same person
in this case we see Taylor Brown and
Tyler Browning we can do the same thing
there's a little bit more variation here
so we might determine this is not the
same person
so after we
um sort of go through that process of
creating features for each pair that
we're interested in we end up with a
data set that looks like this where we
have a lot of different features and
that you're not limited to like first
name distance last name distance dob
distance there's like many different
features that you
create for record linkage so you'll have
a data set with features and then this
same person column that is currently
blank that we need to fill in
and so hopefully now that the data is in
this format it's starting to look very
much like a machine learning problem
um and so kind of stepping back for a
second like why is this hard so I've
I've sort of framed this as record
linkage can be rebranded as like a very
typical prediction problem so why why is
this so difficult
and after years of working on record
language
problems I have come to the opinion that
record linkage is very conceptually
simple but it's very operationally hard
and there's a couple things that make
that like make it super hard the first
one is scale so
um as we sort of seen in the previous
example this prediction that we're doing
is happening at the record pair level
and so if you
um imagine you are linking a data set
with one million records by the time you
like blow that out to the pair level
you're in the space of like almost 500
trillion record pairs so um as you can
imagine it's very computationally
expensive if you don't know sort of the
right tricks to do or if you're not
super careful with how you do it
um so that's the first Challenge and
then the second challenge is that just
because we know that we can think about
record linkage as a prediction problem
doesn't mean that we know how to
generate these predictions so a few
slides back you know we we have these
features but we don't have any labels
and we don't really have we might not
have intuitive sense of how to convert
these features into that project
and so we're left with some tough
questions the first is what I just
mentioned how do you convert features or
distance measures into a prediction
and then the second is like once you do
make predictions how do you know if
they're good this is often a problem
because ground truth labeled data can be
really hard to find in record linkage
scenarios and so this second question
um like evaluating your process you
would hope could be easy but often it's
not
and then the last question
say you you do have some way of
evaluating your performance and the
performance is not as good as you want
it to be
is there anything that you can do about
like is there a mechanism in the record
linkage process or the tool that you're
using that would allow you to make the
performance
so to demonstrate why those are such
tough questions and to hopefully
motivate why we think that the name
match tool adds value I'm going to walk
through sort of the five most common
record linkage approaches
so starting with
um the simplest exact matching this
basically decides what a link is by
saying if the first and the last name in
The dob match exactly then it's a link
if they don't match exactly then it's
not a link
um so obviously this is very simple and
fast um so those are the pros it can
also
he it rarely leads to false
um positives
and so those are the pros of this method
but then conversely like
because this is sort of a very basic
um basic method we can end up with a lot
of false negatives in this approach so
anytime there's a typo you know like
you're not gonna get it via exact
matching
um and the reason I say that there's
likely false negatives is because again
in this case there's no
um no ground truth labels there's no
model in sight so we're really just
guessing at the number of false
negatives we might like sample our data
and notice some but there's really not a
systematic way of content
and then there's also not a way to
improve if you
if you happen to see that these two
records have a minor typo and you want
them to be linked there's no way to make
that happen via exact match
so the next
um approach we'll look at is rule-based
matching which is basically where the
user just defines every possible
situation that could result in a link so
they might say for example two records
should be linked if these two Fields
match or if those two Fields match or if
those three Fields kind of match and so
on and so on
and so
um this the benefit of this is that the
user clearly has like a lot of control
in what's happening but the downside is
that it can be really time consuming
because you just like kind of can add
rules to Infinity
um as you keep noticing things
um and again
so I yeah I say that in this method you
actually have the ability to make
improvements which is really important
but there's at the end of the day still
no way to actually quantify the errors
that you're
making um so
fuzzy matching is a really broad term so
I want to clarify what I mean here
um
if in this context I'm talking about
fuzzy matching as like
when you have distance measures you can
kind of do like a very crude way of
combining them and then Rank by that so
imagine that you just took a simple
average of your first name distance last
name distance and dob distance and then
ranked your pairs according to that
measure and then kind of like did an
eyeball test and Drew a threshold
somewhere that's what I mean by fuzzy
matching here
um and so
again there's no way with no ground
truth no model there's no way to
actually quantify the errors that we're
making via this process
you can kind of improve performance by
um you know tweaking the way that you're
combining those features in some way or
by
um refining where you're kind of drawing
that threshold but you still don't have
a ton of control and ability to to know
what areas you're making
um so finally we'll get into some
probabilistic methods so
often when we want to build a machine
learning model but we don't have any
labeled data we are forced to turn to
unsupervised methods and so that's
exactly what happens in the popular tool
called Fastlane
um so here we use an algorithm like em
to estimate parameters in a model then
we use that model to convert our
distance measures into predicted
probabilities
and technically fastlink does output
performance metrics but
um because there's no labels these are
not um
these are not performance metrics that
are measured from the data they're
estimated from the model
and so they can be helpful but you still
kind of have to take them with a grain
of salt a lot of this
and then I say no in the Improvement
column here because I've had some
experience using fastlink where based on
the characteristics of my data or based
on the how I set up the fast link the
performance wasn't very good and I
didn't know like there was there wasn't
a clear um
for me to make it better
because it's an unsupervised model
um so lastly we will look at Active
Learning methods this is the method that
is used in the popular record linkage
package called to do
and what happens here is that the
algorithm finds pairs that it's really
confused about or it's like having a
really hard time making a prediction for
and then it prompts the user to label
them whether it's a match or a non-match
and then based on the labels that it
gets from this process it trains a model
and is able to then predict
um or change the distance measures into
predicted probabilities
um and again like fastlink you you do
get performance metrics out of this but
because your ground truth data that you
have is very limited in this setting
they're again like estimated from the
model rather than measured from the data
itself
and then you also do have some ability
to improve performance using Hadoop
because you know you can the algorithm
will keep giving you pairs to label
until you decide that your board of
labeling and want to stop and so sort of
the more time that you invest in that
labeling process the more
um ground truth you'll be giving it and
likely the better the model will get
it so
um looking at this list you can see that
there's not really like one perfect
solution to
um those really tough questions that we
saw on the previous slide and
um I would say like generally
performance improves as you go down this
list from sort of the very crude exact
matching method to like getting more and
more supervised in a sense as you go
down and so
um
but what we're really
looking for in a record linkage tool is
is green yeses in the last two columns
where not only do we get good
performance but we can observe that
performance and we can improve the
performance if we need to
with that we will turn our attention to
name match and how we have tried to
address those challenges
so starting with the basics name matches
a python package and command line tool
for probabilistic record linkage
um I'm sort of going to spoil my own
presentation by just cutting to the
Chase and sharing how we answer these
tough questions
so in terms of how we convert features
into a prediction we do that using
supervision we train a model on labeled
data and then we use it to get predicted
probabilities and I'll show you where
the label data comes from in a few
slides
um how do we know if the links we make
are good well because we have this
labeled data we can do a pretty standard
evaluation procedure where we you know
we train on some of the label data we
evaluate using Precision they call AUC
on the held out here
and then last if you think that the
links you make are not good can you make
them better and
um the answer with name matches yes
there's several opportunities for
customization in this tool
um sort of the most notable is
um the the user has the ability to write
python that will be used to determine
like what types of links are not allowed
so say the prediction model predicts
that two records match you can write
python to say like if this is what it
looks like then that's an invalid match
um and that can help
um improve your performance
so
um jumping back to the high level
um what name match does is starts by
taking in one or more data sets
um then we identify pairs of records
that refer to the same person we use
that information to assign a universal
person identifier to each record
and then lastly we output the input data
sets but now they have this extra person
identifier column attached
so this next or the second step is
really where all the magic happens and
so I don't want to gloss over it too
quickly I'll take you one level deeper
into what's actually happening here
so
um this first step is called blocking
and what happens here is that we filter
out
um a lot of pairs that are just so
unrealistically not like similar that we
we don't even need to waste the
computational effort of looking deeper
an example of this would be if you see
records
um with the name Melissa McNeil and
Zubin gelva you can once you see how
different the names are you don't need
to waste time like
calculating exactly how far the name the
first name is the middle name the last
name the address you can kind of just
like set it aside and move on to the
more complex examples
um so after blocking we are at the point
where we can generate that prediction
data set that we saw a few slides
earlier and so we would have our our
distance metrics in there like
um at a distance in the first name at a
distance in the last name soundex
difference of the middle name you can
really go crazy with whatever features
you want and once we have that data set
we will train our supervised learning
model
and then finally we will predict p-match
or the probability that two records
refer to the same person and set a
threshold for what distinguishes a
predicted match and a predicted
non-match
so I also want to point out this third
step because it can be really important
too so this third step is what we call
clustering and I think it's easiest to
explain visually so if you look on the
right
if you think of each of those circles as
a record and then each line has a
predicted link between those records
then you can see like the top three
there's three records they were all
predicted to be the same person
um on the right there's three records
two of them like two of the possible
three pairs were predicted to be the
same person
but what we do during clustering is we
identify the connected components in
this network and assign them the same
unique ID so here you've seen like now
the top three records are all referred
to as person a the records on the right
are referred to as person B and so on so
this is how we kind of do the very last
step of getting that person identifier
for each record
okay so as some of you may have guessed
based on the fact that name match
requires labeled data unfortunately not
all linking tasks are going to be
suitable for name match there are two
requirements in order to use it that
we'll go through now
um
the first requirement is that all
records have first name last name and
some birth information either like the
full birth date or the birth year
and you can also have
um you know address phone number middle
name race gender you can always include
those in your link but these are the
only three that are required because of
how much of the like heavy lifting they
do in in the performance of our
prediction model
so all of the
um records have to have that and then
some not all but some of your records
have to meet these three criteria so you
have to have a ground truth person
identifier
um that already exists in in the data
you have to have people that show up in
multiple records and you have to have
variation in the personally identifiable
information that shows up across records
and so this second requirement might
seem a little
chaotic at the moment but I think
hopefully if we go through an example
it'll help so here you see this data set
meets the requirements because it has an
existing ground truth identifier and
social security number
it has people that show up multiple
times here
ssn123-456789 shows up with two records
and then also important is when this
person shows up multiple times they
sometimes have variation in in their
name so once they are referred to as
Jessica and once they're referred to as
Jesse
so we see now the structure of this that
this requirement takes but we still
might not necessarily know why this is
so useful but I think to see you can
start
um answering these questions so our
records one and two the same person well
they have different Social Security
numbers so we say no our records one and
three the same person well they have the
same Social Security number so we'll say
yes so on and so on until suddenly you
have ground truth labels that you can
use to train this model
and so what does that actually get us
um now that we have labels our machine
learning problem becomes a supervised
machine learning problem
which gets us higher performance
relative to unsupervised and active
learning methods and very importantly it
finally gives us the ability to compute
evaluation metrics for our linking
process
okay so at this point you might be
thinking one of two things one is like
that structure was so obscure like do
you actually even see that in the real
world and it can be rare at times but
I'm I can assure you that it does exist
so one
um type of data that we that very
frequently meets this requirement is
arrest records and that's because you
know a person can get arrested more than
once they often have typos in their name
or give a fake name or something like
that and then very importantly anytime
you're arrested or at least in most
jurisdictions you're going to be
fingerprinted and assigned a unique
identifier and then if you're arrested
again you'll get fingerprinted again and
linked
back so
um arrest records like based on those
three criteria like almost always meet
this requirement
the next thing that you might be
thinking is if your data already has a
ground truth identifier why do you need
to do record linkage or why do you need
to use name match
um that's a very valid question but I
think what we see often is that in data
sets where ground truth is an option
like somebody had the option of
um
filling in their social security number
it's often not required and so you'll
you'll end up with a data set where like
some of the Social Security numbers are
filled in but not all of them
and so you can use that to your
advantage by using the records with
social security number to generate this
labeled data set that you need and then
use name match to fill in uh person
identifiers for the remaining people
that did not list their social security
number
um
okay so I'll go through this quickly
because I think I've already
um evangelized a lot I thought name much
but um there's a few things that make it
special uh ground truth requirement
enable supervised learning and built-in
performance evaluation
um we have this ability to for the user
to Define customizable constraints which
can help the user like encode logic that
they have in their mind about like how
records should and should not associate
with with each other into the name
matching process
and then lastly one thing that sets its
name match apart is that we have what's
called like incremental mode where if
you say you already ran name match on
five million records and now your
partner comes and says like oh here's a
thousand more like you can just add
those 1000 to the 5 million that you
already linked and that'll save you a
lot of time rather than having to
re-link everything
okay so we're gonna go into an example
but um before that I just wanted to walk
quickly through the steps for actually
using name much
um so first you fill out some
configuration details either in a yaml
file or a python dictionary
um then you have the option of writing
these custom constraints in Python then
you can run a match either via python or
the command line tool and finally you'll
get a performance report output that you
should review
so diving into this example
um
imagine we want to measure the impact of
a summer mentoring program on grade
point average and employment
lucky for us we have these three data
sets sitting there we have a program
study roster a school records data set
and an employment records data set and
our task is going to be to measure the
average GPA and the average number of
hours worked for students that did and
did not participate in this mentoring
program
so this is what our three data sets look
like the study roster is one record per
person the school records um one record
per student per year per school they
attended so here you can see you know
there's the school the year the person
information stuff about their attendance
and GPA
um and then lastly the employment
records data set has one record per
person per job so you have record ID
person information social security
number
um wages earned hours worked things like
that
so always when we're considering using
name match the first step is to make
sure we meet the requirements so
um very quickly we can see that we meet
the first requirement all three of our
data sets have first name last name and
DOB
um to see if we meet the second like
harder requirement we can look more
closely at our employment records data
set
um the first thing we notice is that we
have social security number which is our
ground truth identifier
we have some people that show up more
than once Keisha Miller Travis Smith
and then we also have some variation in
pii so Keisha Miller has a typo in her
last name Travis Smith has a typo in his
dob that's going to be really helpful
for training our model
um so we do meet the requirements and so
we move on to the first step which is to
fill in this configuration file
so the first section of the config is
where we Define which data sets we want
linked so what you do is you kind of
assign like a short descriptive name for
each data set here I'm calling them
roster school and employment and then
under each of them you just tell it the
file path of where to find that file and
then the record ID column to use to
identify records uniquely
um the second part of our config is
where we tell it which fields we want it
to use during linking so here we're just
going to do four
um first name last name dob and ground
truth
and so
um each little like chunk here follows
the same format and you need to give the
variable a name which I'm showing now
then you need to give the variable a
compare type and I think right now we
have string date number
categorical so what you put as the
compare type will determine what
distance measures are computed on that
future
um and then the last thing that we need
to do is tell it where to find this
information in each of our files so in
the roster data set our first name
column is in all caps in the school data
set it's called fname the reason that we
allow this is just to sort of limit the
pre-processing that you have to do so
you don't have to like make sure all of
your data sets have the same column
names to begin with
um and then the last thing to point out
on this slide is this ground truth
variable so it has kind of this special
compare type called unique ID
and which this is where we tell it like
use this to build your training data
and then it's blank for a roster in
school because we don't have any ground
truth in those fields we only have
social security number in our employment
data
so every time you run name match you'll
have exactly one variable in this list
that has that compare type unique ID
and then the last section of the config
is where you can just Define like more
General parameters about how you want
the linking to work so
um here we're telling it like if you're
going to parallelize use eight workers
when we have our labeled data use 90 to
train 10 to evaluate
um optimize the threshold based on
performance and things like that
and then
um so that's all that's required for
running name match but it's often a good
idea to write these constraints
and so I'll give you a quick example so
say you ran name match and it comes back
and tells you that these two records
refer to the same person
you might believe them at first you know
Jennifer Lee and Jenny Lee they have the
same birthday that seems reasonable
but then on closer inspection you
realize that this poor person attended
school for 464 days in a single school
year and this would be very hard for the
computer to like know that that is not
possible but as a human we can
immediately see it and say like
I hope this is not real because that
poor person
attended way too much school
um so what we can do about it now is add
this chunk to this is valid link
function that's a part of name match so
what this function does is it takes in
the predicted links a data frame of
predicted links and it returns an
indicator column for whether that link
is valid
and so by default you know there's no
constraints in this function but then
the user can start slotting in
constraints here so what we're showing
it here is
um
if two records have the same school year
and the sum of their attendance days is
greater than 365 days set the valid
indicator to false and now when we rerun
name match it'll know to skip any
records that look like that
um one more example
um this is uh two links or two records
that name match told us or links from
the mentoring study program roster Mark
Johnson Mark Johnson
common name but like exact match we
would probably say that we agree except
for the fact that we know that our study
roster already has one record per person
and so any link between study roster
records should be invalid
and so in order to encode that we just
go back to this function
plot one more thing in here where we say
if both of the records have data set
equals to roster then set the valid
indicator to false
okay so now that we have our config file
all set up and our constraints written
we just have to run name match we
install it via pip and then we can run
it via the command line or run it via
python both cases are pretty simple
you're just like passing it the config
file and the constraints file that you
already defined
um and then you run it and you'll get a
lot of hopefully helpful
um blog information
and then after it finishes this is now
what your data looks like so it looks
exactly as it did before name match but
now you have this cluster ID column
appended
and this is the column that can be used
as a universal person identifier across
all of your data sets
so here you can see the two green
records have the same cluster ID and
that's indicating that you know Jake
Holloway in our program roster is the
same as Jacob Holloway in our employment
record
foreign
and then after you have
um
looked at that you can turn to the
performance report so there's two like
sections of this um the first is here
where you kind of have like
standard machine learning evaluation
metrics Precision recall AC all of these
are computed out of sample on a small
portion of our training data or of our
labels data
um and then the second section here kind
of just gives you some key stats about
like how your input records became
people throughout the process so as you
see here like we started with 22 000
records we like would have had to do 249
million possible pairs if we didn't have
the magic of blocking
um instead we only looked at about 31
000 we predicted that around 4 000 of
them were links
um our constraints helped us eliminate
five false positives and we are left
around 17 000 people across all of these
22 000 records
so finally we can answer our research
question
and what we see is that the people who
received mentoring have higher gpas and
higher number of employment hours than
those who did not receive mentoring so
we're very excited we have used record
linkage to show that this mentoring
program was a huge success
um so I think I'm running out of time
maybe but I'll I'll wrap up here
um record linkage hopefully I've
convinced you is a really important
processing step
um in many data tasks it can also be
very interesting and a very complex
problem to solve
um Quality matters a lot because
if your record linkage is bad then any
type of analysis task that you're doing
afterwards is going to be influenced by
the errors that happened in your record
linkage procedure and so quality matters
and in order to make sure that quality
is good and improve it you need the
ability to to measure
um to do this evaluation
um with name match you get
the Improvement in performance that
comes with supervised learning you also
get built-in evaluation that comes with
supervised learning and then the user
has a lot of control via these custom
constraints that they can Define
um so we have some exciting work on the
horizon so please check us out and
contribute this is the link
and thank you
thanks a lot um I definitely learned a
lot about linkage it may match
um I'm opening a forum for questions uh
okay
hi
um
have you ever looked at like the
stability of your matches I I imagine if
you say person a is person B in this
data set and that precludes them
preclude someone else from being matched
the person B
um so to a certain extent the order in
which you assign links matters
um have you ever thought about shuffling
and seeing whether you result in the
same linkages if you were to just match
in a different order yeah that's a good
question so I guess one thing is unless
you have constraints that prevent
um multiple links the like you're not
going to preclude somebody else from
linking to this record by linking to
them first it'll just be the case that
all three of those records will refer to
the same person if you did have a
constraint that like said only one link
per record then you would definitely get
into that problem and by default
um the the links are considered in
descending order of predicted
probability so you know the idea there
is that you're getting the best links
first and then
um up to up into a threshold
um we have experimented with other
orderings because in some projects it
makes more sense to do like a
chronological ordering rather than a
performance ordering and
we haven't done like a super
scientific comparison I guess but
um generally I'd say it's it's only the
links like on the very margin that are
going to be
um to change there and it really matters
how like heavy-handed your constraints
are as well
thanks
first of all thank you so much for
sharing this this is really interesting
work I work on similar problem but uh
instead of a person I do matching based
on my business names so my question was
um since this open source can we use
this customize it I know build a
completely different solution for based
on
business names this is on our list of
future things that we want to do okay so
um right now name match has been very
like tailored to doing her
matching so all the default thresholds
and the def like the requirements of
first and last name dob are all tailored
to people but
um I think with a few minor tweaks you
could expand it to something like
business names
um and that's something we've also been
curious about
great thank you
so I have a question about the ground
Truth uh for I think the questions that
I'd imagine you'd be exploring social
security number seems like a perfectly
established uh great ground truth to use
but for other domains that don't
necessarily have that I wanted to ask
you uh did you explore using any
artificially created ground truths which
or did you just use as a signature is
available
um could you explain what you mean by
artificially created so it's something
really simple would be like a
concatenation of like a couple different
columns uh
yeah so it's a good question I think the
problem with
creating a ground truth indicator that's
based on the features that you're going
to be using in your model is you're
going to end up creating like a
deterministic
mapping between features and the label
and so
um I think then the model would only
learn
the ability to encode the exact logic
that you use to create the ground truth
um and so we haven't explored that but
it does make a challenge like if you
don't have access to this fingerprint ID
or social security number you kind of
have to get like a little bit more
creative with
um where you're finding your your label
data like in one case we had um
student IDs and
it's really easy to find like examples
of non-matches because it's like This
Record is probably not the same person
as that record just probabilistically
but it's really the the ones that you
have a hard time finding
uh do you get records about like name
changes
and stuff yeah so um one big question we
have is like what the the fairness
implications of record linkages because
you know it's more common for women to
have significant name changes when you
do fuzzy matching you're often linking
looking for like you know one character
difference or two character differences
if somebody suddenly has a completely
new last name then it can be a lot
harder to link
um in these cases that's when like
having address information or
um extra information like gender can be
helpful in the link
uh yeah I'm curious if the model takes
into account commonality of names I'd
imagine that there would be a lot more
false positives with uh John Smith than
for a less common name
um and if not is there some other way to
account for any demographic bias that
might be introduced there yeah so um we
definitely do account for name
commonness currently so we have a
measure in our futures data set that
says how often that name appears and
um so like because we have that feature
in our data set the model can learn to
you know use that information as is
helpful earlier in the process when we
do blocking we also factored in a little
bit more manually so we have thresholds
for when records when record pairs get
through the blocking process and there
we make the threshold lower if it's a
really rare name and higher if it's a
really common name because
um
the bigger your data set say you're
linking like every voter in the state of
California you know there's going to be
a lot of people with the same names and
you don't want that to generate
um too many false positives and so there
that's another uh place where having
more information like race gender
address phone number can be helpful to
to distinguish between the people with
really common
um yeah okay I think we have time for
one last question and then um
oh yeah
thank you
um apologies to the others uh my
questions and uh thanks a lot uh thank
you Melissa